[ __ ], [ __ ], c'est comme trois
secondes plus tard, nous sommes morts
Jésus-Christ
près du front, il n'y a pas de zone de sécurité pour
les civils, ce n'est tout simplement pas possible,
c'est très très intense, beaucoup de gens
meurent, beaucoup de soldats, beaucoup de
civils reçoivent  blessés,
je veux dire, ce que nous faisons est assez fou mais
c'est ce qu'il faut faire.
Je dirige un groupe qui aide les civils et nous
emmenons les gens hors des zones de guerre vers
des zones plus sûres en Ukraine et à l'extérieur du
pays. [La
musique]
est
[la musique]
nous  J'ai évacué beaucoup de gens maintenant,
comme des milliers de personnes depuis que nous avons
commencé. Je veux juste éloigner ces enfants
de la souffrance.
[Musique]
c'est une énorme responsabilité
la moitié du temps où tu décides de leur sort
et mec, c'est beaucoup si  c'est ce que
demande le travail et c'est ce que je fais
hier,
quelques personnes là-bas, c'était
tellement désolé
alors quelqu'un m'a dit il y a un an que je
ferais toutes ces choses, je ne pense pas que
je les aurais cru toi  je sais et nous voilà
[Musique]
euhétranger au
revoir
tout véhicule dans la zone militaire est une
cible qu'ils peuvent cibler quelqu'un avec de
l'artillerie et évidemment nous pouvons mettre des têtes à
portée, vous y êtes exposé
efficacement, tous les systèmes d'armes existent,
vous ne le faites vraiment pas.  Je ne veux pas être là une
seconde de plus que ce dont tu as besoin, je
dis que le [ __ ] de départ est tellement
ouvert à tous les gars qui viennent ici et à tous
les gars qui font ça pendant aussi longtemps qui
ne peuvent jamais se faire tuer tous les jours, c'est
le  la réalité,
mais en fin de compte, nous avons une
mission ici et la mission est d'aider
ces gens
[Musique]
lorsque vous évacuez ces gens de
ces zones très mauvaises, il sait ce que
vous faites, c'est important et c'est pour
quelque chose et c'est ce qui me motive dans
la démo
[Musique]
ouais c'est le set numéro sept ouais,
l'énergie soufflée
donc j'ai dormi si longtemps qu'il a raté
une bonne passe au début
[Musique]
ce que nous faisons tous les jours nous'  nous conduisons beaucoup,
nous n'avons pas beaucoup d'activité physique, vous
savez, nous sommes simplement assis dans la voiture
tout le temps et parfois nous devons
courir avec les plaques et tout ce que cela demande,
cela demande beaucoup d'efforts, donc c'est bien de
soyez en forme, vous connaissez Panda mentalement
aussi parce que vous obtenez des endorphines, vous
obtenez une libération de testostérone, vous vous sentez
bien, vous vous sentez bien pour la journée, il fait beau
et humide ensemble en équipe, alors oui,
j'essaie de vous garder gros
[Musique]
merci,
notre chef apprend lentement, il essaie, il
essaie d'être l'homme le plus grand, je veux dire
faire des plats honnêtes et de haute
qualité, mais il est beau donc c'est
bon, nous avons toléré les
étrangers
[Musique]
Je pense qu'une partie de cela vient du fait de
brûler un  un peu de stress et aussi
garder le lien élevé, garder tout le monde
sur la même longueur d'onde
euh et c'est très amusant comme si c'était
toujours un peu un rire,
nous y allons en premier et vous allez
soutenir nous y allons  être à
distance ça va être assez
dangereux quand on y va donc il faut voir je
ne sais pas je ne sais même pas si on va y aller
parfois étranger étranger
étranger
tu multiplies ça par quatre ou cinq  nous
dépensons, vous savez, cinq six dollars rien que
pour les pneus,
cela coûte beaucoup d'argent de continuer à faire ça,
mais c'était nécessaire, vous savez, vous
ne pouvez pas prendre de raccourcis et des trucs comme ça
[Musique]
Je vais m'arrêter et parler à  il y a des
gars ici
ouais, de la musique étrangère
ici, avec ce Crossing, tu montes sur une
colline et tu es super exposé au-dessus de la
colline maintenant les Russes sont là, donc en gros,
depuis le virage ici, ils ont une belle
visibilité sur toi, vraiment sympa et ici
aussi  tu dois aller le plus vite
possible pour entrer ici, la première voiture
pourrait ne pas être remarquée et la deuxième
carte, j'aurai une [ __ ] de préparation W pour
quelqu'un qui arrive donc je pense que si nous y allons tous les deux
, je serai comme [ __ ]
ton cul mais tu as le pied le plus occupé
au sol et bien j'ai une autre voiture plus rapide
que la tienne non je sais de manière significative
ouais nous allons dans un village qui est euh
juste sur le devant à quelques centaines de
mètres les entrées ont euh l'ennemi a
ils ont les yeux rivés sur leurs armes, donc ce que
nous allons faire, c'est suivre certaines
procédures opérationnelles standard des Sops et euh,
ça avancera aussi vite que possible,
j'espère que nous pourrons faire sortir ces familles,
euh parce que les Russes sont sacrément
proches et, euh,
obtenez  rentrez-les sains et saufs et ce sera une
bonne journée.
Tireur d'élite,
tout véhicule dans une zone militaire est une
cible et si nos voitures sont vues par les
Russes par les drones, ils peuvent
les cibler avec de l'artillerie et évidemment nous pouvons
faire passer les têtes
à travers cette partie aussi vite que possible.  il est possible que
des étrangers y
aillent et tout le village était
déjà foutu et maintenant c'est encore pire,
tout est exposé,
tout est exposé ici,
c'est aussi bien que nous avons
mieux, l'
homme
ne nous verra pas d'ici parce que
ouais hein
[Musique]
allez, il  il faut qu'on accélère l'
étranger
alors [ __ ] d'ouverture,
[ __ ] de poussière, mec, voyons
si nous sommes en clair, laisse-en 10, nous en
avons
parce que nous allions dans un
endroit assez dangereux, nous prenons deux voitures avec nous
au cas où quelque chose se produirait, nous  nous avons un
véhicule de secours vers lequel nous pouvons transférer,
mais la route était extrêmement mauvaise et nous
avons dû aller très vite car les endroits
où les routes étaient les pires étaient les
modules exposés que les Russes
surveillaient donc vous ne pouvez pas vraiment ralentir
là-bas  nous avons failli nous écraser, un des
véhicules a failli sortir de la route et
la deuxième voiture, nous avons cassé la suspension
juste à cause des routes et de l'état de la route
ouais,
c'est cassé, ce n'est pas bon,
merci Michael, nous avons eu la voiture pendant
exactement un jour, d'accord, c'est bien.
le fait qu'aucune de ces voitures n'est
morte mec, il est impressionnant
ouais et bien euh donc c'est super dangereux
de conduire dessus
euh je pourrai juste le mettre dans
ta voiture et je conduirai derrière lui je
ne me sentais pas à l'aise de continuer avec
ça  "
Je ne pourrai pas nous rendre
à un point de stabilisation où nous
pourrons arriver à l'hôpital à temps simplement
parce que le véhicule ne fonctionne pas
correctement. Bien sûr, cela nous expose à
un grand risque si l'un des véhicules
tombe en panne, mais c'est ce qui  c'est
étranger
[Musique]
lotion
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci
exactement
étranger
[Musique]
euh ouais mais bien sûr mec d'abord
j'évacuais alors c'est
un endroit sympa où tu pourrais t'arrêter dans un hôtel
hier
[Musique]
étranger
merci
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
traité comme des frères
euh c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut être là pour expérimenter comme s'il
n'y avait pas grand chose sur la planète qui corresponde à ça
donc c'est plutôt génial
[  Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
mais je suis désolé
parfois, il faut qu'un être cher
meure avant de se dire oh, nous devons
partir
étrangers, il y
a deux enfants dans cette maison, nous
ne pouvons pas les prendre comme si nous ne l'étions pas
autorisé, donc les enfants restent ici,
c'est fou, tu essaies toujours plus
pour les enfants, parce qu'ils ont un
avenir devant eux et ils
ne devraient certainement pas être là-bas à
l'étranger